en un vídeo anterior hablamos del grado
de sustitución de los alternos y eso nos
va a ayudar para hablar de la
estabilidad de los alternos en general
los al que nos más sustituidos son los
más estables así es que en el que no he
sustituido es más estable que uno mono
sustituido en el que no three sustituido
es más estable que uno y sustituido y el
al que no más estable de todos es el
tetra sustituido por aquí tenemos un al
que no mono sustituido tenemos
únicamente este grupo al kilo enlazado a
uno de los carbonos del doble enlace por
acá tenemos un al que no de sustituido
porque tenemos estos dos grupos al kilos
enlazados a uno de los carbonos del
doble enlace y los al que nos y
sustituidos son más estables que los al
que nos monos sustituidos ahora para
explicar por qué sucede esto necesitamos
regresar a la idea de la estabilidad del
oscar vocaciones que vimos en algún
vídeo anterior por
y a la derecha tenemos un kart vocación
secundario este carbono con carga
positiva está directamente enlazado con
dos grupos al kilos entonces es un kart
vocación secundario y además un carbono
con carga positiva tiene una hibridación
sp2 este carbono está sp2 y brid izado
por lo que la geometría a su alrededor
es plana y lo podemos ver en esta foto
de acá este es el kart vocación sp2 y
brie visado y podemos ver que hay una
geometría plana a su alrededor porque
estos tres enlaces están en un mismo
plano este kart vocación tiene una
hibridación sp2 y justo como tiene una
hibridación sp2 entonces debería de
tener un orbital p no híbrido y es justo
lo que tenemos acá
este es nuestro orbital p no híbrido y
lo que está estabilizando a esta carga
positiva del carbó catión son
los dos grupos al kilos este grupo
metilo y este otro grupo metilo están
donando electrones para estabilizar a
esta molécula a través de un efecto
llamado hiper conjugación por aquí
tenemos uno de esos grupos metidos y
observa este enlace por la orientación
en la que se encuentra puede donar
densidad de electrones al orbital p de
este carbono sp2 civilizado y eso
estabiliza al kart vocación y lo mismo
pasa con este grupo metilo por acá
también puede donar un poco de su
densidad de electrones estabilizando la
carga positiva de éste carbó catión este
efecto se llama hiper conjugación ahora
por ejemplo este enlace con este
hidrógeno no puede hacer nada al
respecto justo por la geometría en la
que se encuentra pero bueno estos dos
grupos al kilos estabilizan la carga
positiva del carbó catión y algo muy
parecido sucede con los al que nos por
a este carbono también estabilizado sp2
y también tenemos estos grupos al kilos
que le están donando densidad de
electrones los carbonos sp2 civilizados
son más electro negativos que los
carbonos sp3 civilizados así es que esta
donación de densidad de electrones puede
ayudar a estabilizar a este carbono
estabilizando al al que no completo y es
por esto que observamos con mayor
frecuencia al que nos más sustituidos
ahora veamos unos ejemplos ordenamos a
estos al que nos por estabilidad vamos a
empezar clasificando los por su grado de
sustitución vamos a empezar con este al
que no por acá nos fijamos en estos dos
carbonos del doble enlace y a veces
ayuda mucho dibujar a los hidrógenos
enlazados y ya que los dibujamos ahora
si queda muy claro que tenemos aquí dos
grupos alc y los enlazados a uno de los
carbonos del doble enlace entonces este
es un al que no he sustituido
ahora vamos a analizar el segundo al que
no aquí están los dos carbonos de
nuestro enlace doble y otra vez opinó
que es muy útil dibujar los hidrógenos
enlazados con estos carbono y ya que los
dibujamos queda muy claro que tenemos un
único grupo alquiló enlazado con uno de
los carbonos del doble enlace entonces
lo que tenemos aquí es un al que no mono
sustituido y ahora vamos a clasificar
este al que no aquí están los dos
carbonos del doble enlace el carbono de
la izquierda tiene un solo hidrógeno por
acá y entonces tenemos 1 2 y 3 grupos al
kilos por lo que este es un al que no 3
sustituido sabemos que los al que nos
más sustituidos son más estables que los
al que nos menos sustituidos lo que nos
dice que entre estos tres al que nos
éste es el más estable de todos es el al
que no más estable de estos tres después
el siguiente al que no más
estable de estos tres es el di
sustituido y finalmente el al que no
menos estable de todos es el al que no
mono sustituido este es el al que no
menos estable el al que no tree
sustituido es el al que no más estable y
el al que no mono sustituido es el menos
estable bueno ya vimos qué tan estables
son los al que nos si cambiamos el grado
de sustitución pero ahora veamos qué
pasa si tenemos los isómeros por aquí
tenemos un cis 2 butano y por acá un
trans 2 wood en estos dos al que nos son
isómeros y los dos son sustituidos pero
cuál de estos dos es más estable bueno
pues el trans 2 vote no es más estable
que el cis éste al que no es más estable
porque sucede eso
bueno pues podemos pensar en eso en
términos del impedimento estético si
observamos el cis 2 wood en estos grupos
metilo
bastante estorbosos y se estorban
mutuamente si se encuentran del mismo
lado del enlace doble este impedimento
estético entre estos dos grupos
voluminosos provoca que se desestabilice
e éste al que no que se dé se estabilice
el 62 bote no tenemos un incremento en
el impedimento estético y eso de cree en
venta la estabilidad del al que no si
nos ponemos a ver al trans 2 buque no
podemos ver que sus dos grupos metilo
están en lados opuestos del enlace doble
y eso hace que crezca el impedimento
estético y por lo tanto incremente la
estabilidad de la molécula y justo esta
es la razón por la que el trans 2 vote
no es más estable